it's May 25th do you know where your
towel is yes folks it is towel day and
for months I'm finally gonna fulfill the
thing I've been saying I would do for a
long time we just talked about the
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy this is
my personal preferred Edition this is
the more than completed Hitchhiker's
Guide to the galaxy complete and on a
bridge except not really because this
was printed back when it was only for
books as opposed to the 5/6 if you
consider the extra one Canon or not but
yeah I talked about this thing because I
love it I love this book series to death
and I love this property to death so
first let's just talk a little bit about
the history of what G he of what
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy even is
because it's frankly a lot of stuff so
this was this entire thing that I'm
about to talk about and gush over was
created by the sadly late Douglas Adams
who was a science fiction writer he did
he worked on Doctor Who for a while he
you know did various writings and he
worked at the BBC and they produced for
him or with him the original radio show
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy which
was the original format that this first
came in and those sort of first few
series of that were later than readapted
by Adams into the first two books which
are Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy and
the restaurant at the end of the
universe he then began to work in novel
form first and then things would get
adapted later so then came life universe
and everything then so long and thanks
for all the fish then mostly harmless
and most of those would also see you
know different adaptations in radio
there was also a video game and
there was the movie which came out after
he died but you know all all this stuff
and it is a funny yet oddly nihilistic
stew stronger word but it is it there's
a lot of dark humor in it I mean the
very first book oh this is not a spoiler
this is the starting premise of the
series the first book opens with the
earth being blown up that's how we start
and yet it's very funny so there's so
much that I love about this and and the
the book that is my preferred version
some people prefer the radio versions
and I have heard them and they are quite
good and they're worth listening to but
there are there are little things about
the books that make me prefer them and
it has to do with the language and with
Douglas Adams voice as an author and
what I mean by that I don't mean
dialogue because dialogue comes across
just fine in you know like the in the
radio thing and whatnot but I mean his
word choice and the way in which he
describes things and I'm actually gonna
give you a couple of quick examples of
what I'm talking about
because when you listen to say the radio
or even it you know if you watch see the
BBC miniseries because there were that
too or the movie or like anything that
isn't a novel you get you know the
dialogue and the story both of which are
great but his descriptions add something
a little X and that's something you only
get in the novel's so I'm gonna give you
a couple of examples he's describing
here that these two passages I'm gonna
use are from life the universe and
everything and I'm just picking them
because I think they illustrate what I'm
talking about really well so he's just
describing this emotion that is being
felt and sort of picked up it's like a
vibe
it was hatred implacable hatred it was
cold
not like Isis cold but like a wall is
cold it wasn't personal
not like a randomly flung fist and a
crowd is impersonal but like a computer
issued parking summons is impersonal and
it was deadly again not like a bullet or
a knife is deadly but like a brick wall
across an expressway is deadly and one
more I'll use real quick and I think
I'll make my point so this has our lead
character and I'll talk about characters
in a little bit this is Arthur Dent and
he he is teleported somewhere and he
doesn't end up where he thinks he he
doesn't end up where he was planning to
be and he's alone now if you were to do
this in radio he'd just be going hello
hello and if you were to do this in any
sort of visual format he'd just be
looking around and he'd be alone but you
would miss the way it gets described he
looked around for the others they
weren't there he looked around for the
others again they still weren't there he
closed his eyes he opened them he looked
around for the others they obstinately
persisted in their absence
they obstinately persisted in their
absence that's what I'm talking about
when I say the word choice in the way
that he describes things it makes it
just a little bit extra and that's why I
prefer the books personally because you
know this
the other stuff is Wow we have not all
the other stuff but the the radio plays
definitely are great and a lot of his
voice is in there because you get
entries from the guide itself being read
so you do get a bit of that but stuff
like that having that kind of language
describing the entirety of the story
that makes it the best form in my
opinion so having now let you know what
my favorite one is understand that
mostly when I talk from here on out I'm
talking about the books so plot
characters all this stuff so the things
the plot most of the well the first two
books at least are more just sort of a
series of events it's not really a plot
there's a starting premise which is the
human Arthur Dent gets rescued off of
earth right before it is destroyed by
the Vogons to make way for a hyperspace
bypass in the area and he gets saved by
a friend of his name Ford Prefect who is
not human but is from a small planet
somewhere in the vicinity of Betelgeuse
and he manages to get offworld and he
takes Arthur with him and Arthur spends
the entire series basically befuddled
bewildered and desperately just wanting
a nice cup of tea and while Ford drags
him along and that's the thing Birds
certainly those first two books none of
the characters are really trying to
accomplish anything or if they are they
don't really know that they are in some
cases that I now come back to who I'm
talking about with that but it's such a
wonderfully bizarre universe and I do
want to say you know it's it's too big
to call like a bizarre world it is a
complete universe because it is it is
slightly absurd that vibe runs through
it but you'll have completely different
segments depending on where they go what
bit of history we learn from the guide
and things like that
now the titular Hitchhiker's Guide to
the galaxy the way that comes into play
is Ford is actually a travel travelling
writer for it and so he helps update the
entries he got stuck on earth while
doing a write-up on it and he then
presents the guide to Arthur and that's
how we get a lot of those entries is him
consulting the book basically just
trying to wrap his head around anything
that's going on around him and so that's
where we get some wonderful asides and
we get even in the radio version some
great descriptions of things of
historical events and like I said there
is kind of a bleakness to it it has kind
of a low opinion of like the
intelligence of sentient life basically
like even when dealing with characters
who come from races that are flat-out
described as
hyper-intelligent they're still all kind
they're all kind of idiots and it's it's
just this wonderful looking at the
insane absurdity of the universe that
really should be depressing and just
going well you gotta laugh right and
that's the vibe of these of this whole
thing but there's other characters to
talk about so I mentioned Arthur who's
hapless and endearing
there's Ford who is um let me put it
this way he's the he if you had for word
for a friend you know he was in town cuz
you heard there was a fight at the bar
that's the kind of guy that Ford is then
we've got trillion who unfortunately
doesn't really come into her own as a
character until I would say the third
book she's just kind of there she's not
a bad character but she doesn't feel
properly fleshed out for most of the
first two books which is probably part
of why the movie made the very
ill-advised decision to pump her up as a
potential love interest for Arthur
probably because they didn't know what
else to do with her but she is largely
paired off with my favorite character
who is Zaphod Beeblebrox Zaphod is
Zaphod is a insane and I mean that in
the best possible way and I don't mean
like he has mental illness although he
probably does alright he flat-out does
he has brain damage he did it to himself
but that's kind of the thing the guy's
got two heads he's got three arms not
because his species is like that but
because he got them added to just throw
people off a little bit more he became
the president of the galaxy basically on
a whim on a lark because he thought it
would be fun but he also knows that
somewhere in the back of his brains
there's a better reason for it but he
messed with his own head so he doesn't
know why he's doing stuff but he's still
doing it and my favorite thing about
Zaphod and this again is something the
movie got drastically wrong and I
disliked it so much that honestly I
think I might this might be part of why
I don't like Sam Rockwell which is
unfair but it might be in the mix but
what I love about Zaphod is he's
actually very smart but he is incredibly
lazy he does not want to have to take
the time to plan or to figure stuff out
if he thinks he can get away with not
doing that which is something that the
movie just got the movie just had him be
an idiot but he's described very early
on in the books as being very clever but
one of the things about trying to
interact with him is you don't know when
he's being when he's pretending to be
stupid just to throw people off a game
pretending to be incredibly stupid to
hide the fact that he actually kind of
doesn't know what's going on or actually
genuinely just being stupid but in the
second book especially which is probably
my favorite that's restaurant at the end
of the universe
he get he gets stuck on his own where he
actually has to put thought into stuff
and he has to figure stuff out and he's
pretty good at it but he just doesn't
want to have to do that if he can snap
his fingers and have something else do
the thinking and the planning for him
that's just what he's gonna do and the
freewheeling nature of him I mean he
wouldn't work as a lead character but as
a supporting character as a wild card
who's just there doing stuff and he
doesn't even know why I adore him I love
him to death and then there's the
character who had been initially when I
first read it my favorite character and
that is Marvin Marvin is a robot he's an
Android
who is insanely intelligent and also
incredibly depressed he is so smart that
he knows exactly how wasted his
capacities are when he gets asked to go
to the teleportation room and escort
somebody from there to the bridge and he
is so miserable and he made sure
everybody knows it and I know that
sounds like Oh God who wants to be
around this and that's how everyone
treats him but somehow somehow Douglas
Adams managed to thread that needle cuz
I've talked before about how this is
incredibly hard to do this is one of the
few times where I can cite it that an
author did it and it worked which is to
have a character who is irritating to
the other characters but is not
irritating to the reader or the audience
and Marvin is to me the epitome of like
when that actually worked because I
wouldn't want to actually be around
Marvin but I loved him as a presence and
all of this everyone else you know just
trying to figure out what's going on or
even trying to pick him up and oh don't
bother
like he's imagine if he or could you
know could good calculate pi 250 billion
points that's that's well that's what
Marvin is like and the reason these
books came into my life at a time when I
really kind of needed them I I read
these in seventh grade now sixth grade
had been miserable for me it was it was
the probably the worst year of my K
through 12 life I really had a lousy
sixth grade year so coming into seventh
grade and there were things that were
going better for me but to find this
book series and read something that did
not present the universe as just and
fair and fine and awesome well it does
present it as awesome sometimes but it's
also cruel and sick and uncaring it
presents it that way but still makes you
laugh it I needed it so bad at that age
because if someone if I've been reading
something that just tried to tell me how
beautiful everything is and how it's all
great I just would have rejected it but
for something that says oh yeah I mean
this is man
yes but it's kind of funny right that
help pull me out of what could have
otherwise been a spiral and I I don't
want to tribute that solely to a book
but like I do feel it was an important
thing that came into my life the exact
moment that I needed it and funnily
enough it was the summer after seventh
grade that I saw our Rocky Horror
Picture Show for the first time so like
around that chunk of time like some
things that were super important so sort
of me coming to terms with myself and
life came into my life around that same
time it's kind of funny thinking back on
it the timing of it but the so as I
mentioned my favorite book is probably
restaurant at the end of the universe
I do like almost all of them and this is
sort of well I'll acknowledge some some
faults in it so the third one is
interesting that's like the universe and
everything and that was actually a
reworked pitch for a doctor whose story
so it's actually got the most
straightforward plot because it actually
it has built it has a villain and it has
a traditional climax which is something
neither of which really exists in any of
the other books in the series but it's
because it was adapted for something
that was originally designed with
traditional heroes villains climax etc
but it still feels very much of this
world and what he created to basically
replace what would have been the TARDIS
and the Doctor Who version of this story
I love to death it's called the it'z
it's called the starship beast or math
and I might even like it more than the
heart of gold which is slightly more
iconic but the beast or math it looks
like an Italian bistro and all of the
computers computations are done by
robots on a on a waiter's bill pad
because the premise being that in a
restaurant numbers do not behave the
same way that they do anywhere else and
like there's a whole section I won't
quote it but I will like give you one
concept that it that it mentions sort of
yet that in restaurants they it
discover the mathematical concept of the
reciprocal ooze on which is used to
describe the estimated time of arrival
when somebody makes a reservation and a
reciprocal is on is a number that can
only be described as anything other than
itself meaning the time given for the
estimated time of arrival of the party
for reservation is the one precise
moment in time that nobody will turn up
and it's that it's those kinds of
concepts of like taking something either
scientific and going absurd with it or
takes up or taking something absurd and
making it sound scientific the same
thing happens with the heart of gold
which I mentioned which has the infinite
improbability drive and it's a ship that
can basically do anything so long as you
know precisely to a mathematical
certainty how improbable the thing you
want it to do actually is but as a
result of that anytime you you use it it
causes a whole mess of incredibly
improbable stuff to happen in its wake
as well so that's a lot of fun but
anyway anyway going back to let the
universe and everything about that one
as I said it's got the most
straightforward and traditional story so
in a way it might even be a better
leaping on point at least a narrative
structure wise it does build enough off
the story of the earlier ones that you
can't really start there then there's so
long and thanks for all the fish which
is a quite a different beast in a lot of
ways it's it's got the fewest sci-fi
elements and it actually almost bears
more resemblance to magical realism so
tone wise it actually feels a little bit
more like the Dirk Gently books but it
happens to star over there then so it's
in this series and it also introduces
what I feel is an underrated character
which is the character of Fenchurch and
so long thanks for all the fish is
primarily a romance between Arthur and
Fenchurch and she's borderline Manic
Pixie dream girl except that at the time
the thing was written which I think was
late 80s that wasn't really an
established trope yet so I don't really
feel like I
like take him to task and also like
anytime like Arthur does very much have
that idealized he sees her in his oh you
know completion in my life you know kind
of thing but she also kind of reminds
him at various points like hey I'm right
here like could you involve me in this
whole thing that you're that you've
decided is is going on with you and mean
in your mind and everything else so um I
enjoy her as a character quite a bit the
fifth book mostly harmless is about the
only one that I don't actually like and
actually Douglas Adams himself expressed
some dissatisfaction with it because he
basically he he said he wasn't in the
right frame of mind when he wrote it and
that it was very bleak and I've
mentioned that there's kind of black
humor running through the series as a
whole and there is but the general vibe
has always been so light and it's never
been particularly cruel to its
characters but mostly harmless is kind
of cruel and while it still has all the
same writing flourishes and you know
great dialogue and and things like that
that just slight shift in tone in the
back room makes me enjoy less and I
really don't like the way that it ends
and sort of the note that that it ends
on overall which makes me relatively
receptive to the sixth book that was
written by yoen coffer
yoen Ian I don't know how that name is
pronounced I'll put it there who writes
the Artemis Fowl books um and it's more
satisfying certainly as an endpoint than
mostly harmless was but it does sort of
suffer from the from a little bit of fan
Vicki miss which is like it's pulling
all these things from the earlier books
and Douglas Adams would do that too but
they it feels a little less organical a
little more ooh and then this character
shows up and then this one and then this
think it was like when Wow bagger the
infinitely prolonged showed up in that
and that was basically just a memorable
two scene joke character from the third
that's like ah yeah and then he's a
major playing the sixth one so there's
that buddy it's a pretty good
approximation of douglas adams a--'s
style and like i said it's it's
certainly well more satisfying way to
bring up that six one's called and
another thing but these books and the
humor that is embedded in the characters
that's embedded in the situations that
is just enriched by the descriptions the
narrative it's it means a lot to me
i I do feel that that these were
important in sort of my yes yes oh I
don't when does that happen
okay switch Daisy Co exploration
[Music]
Wednesday well Mama's gonna be taking
you to rehearsal that day so you got to
talk to her about that
yeah well Thursday is gonna be Grammy so
I well can we talk about it in the
morning cool I'll talk to you thank you
we'll talk about it in the morning
we'll talk can you shut my door please
we'll talk about it in the morning
and honestly there's so much more that I
could talk about I could I could happily
go through an entire history of these I
could do I could I could spend a half an
hour talking about each of these books
individually highlighting segments you
know going through the major points and
I'd be delighted to do that I adore
these books and what Douglas Adams's
created was such a massive influence and
I say I think in some ways a lifeline I
needed these stories when they came into
my life and I it's one of the few books
that I have reread or book series the
first four books that I've reread and
will probably continue to reread
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy have
you read it have you heard it
have you seen it have you played it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it whole bunch of stuff to do
because there's buttons and links and
Louanna
I guess likes are like the big thing
driving the algorithm now because that
seems to be what everybody's pushing so
I guess hit the like button also there's
links down there like the patreon and my
socials and whatever click on them
they'll take you places or don't you
don't have to because at the end of the
day folks
you're the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time remember
the answer is 42
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]